[Music]
this morning on the dish a chef note for
changing the perception of Indian
cuisine in America raised in India
marijuana irani came to the u.s. to earn
an MBA but of course he missed the spicy
cuisine of his homeland so he learned
how to cook it himself he continued to
cook for friends while working in the
auto industry in California but I was
dreamed of running his own restaurant in
2009 he took the plunge with his wife
and business partner moving to Asheville
North Carolina and opening chai pani it
was a big hit and just the first of five
restaurants he now runs in Asheville and
Atlanta he's a three-time James Beard
Award nominee and this summer Time
magazine named him one of 31 people
changing the South chef are big that is
big
marwan irani welcome to the dish good
morning and this table Wow can't wait to
dig in you tell us what's here well this
is a combination of Indian Street food
which is what we serve in a restaurants
called shot because eat with your hands
and chat means to lick and also the kind
of food that you would normally get at
home and an Indian family at any given
time anywhere in India if they're
sitting down for a meal it's made up of
multiple components yes a meat and three
think about it meat mate yeah I love
okra you got okra fries and these are
fried and then tossed with a little
chaat masala and chili we've got the
components of what we call a poly in
India so that's mustard greens cooked
with the cumin and mustard seed that's
the Malabar chicken curry and that's
done in a coastal style so there's a
little coconut milk you'll pick up some
lime and also mustard seeds
that's lentils though we call it in
India rice poppadoms and then some of
the street food components that's a dish
called keema Powell we refer to it in
the restaurant it's a sloppy joe or this
might be Jai and that's made with ground
lamb and that's done in a Parsi style
which is what one side of my family is
from and then last over the corner there
is something called corn bail and this
this is the pawnee what I try to do was
make a drink that wasn't just a western
style drink that was just modified to be
Indian but that's done with elderflower
liquer it's a little cilantro and we'll
touch a Prosecco in life let's just
shoot cut to the chase earlier you you
were born in London yeah
raised in India and then educated in the
US I'm what they call a culinary mud yes
yeah I mean that has got to be culture
shock all the way around yeah I mean
moving from England to India I was four
but I grew up with English is my first
language if you run out and think about
it so I came to India almost as an
immigrant even though I was Indian
mm-hmm and had to learn how to speak the
language well I was in a very small town
in India but one of the big influences
in my life and the reason ended up in
America was there was a huge Western
sort of influx of pilgrims that would
come there to visit a spiritual ashram
the Meher Baba spiritual ashram but and
my great aunt ran a bed-and-breakfast
where we put up these Westerners so from
an early age it was exposed to Western
food western movies Western culture and
I grew up with almost more of an
affinity for America as a kid in the
small town in India than I did as an
Indian so when you got to the US for
grad school and you got to was it South
Carolina what kind of culture shock was
there there if any well first landed in
New York and to me in New York was
everything I thought America would look
like in the movies the next step tough
to Columbia South Carolina it's a good
[Laughter]
study but of course I miss my food yeah
so the first place I went to was an
Indian restaurant thinking I'd get the
food that it got back home and it was
everything Indian restaurants look like
in the 90s hi a spicy curry buffet in a
strip mall with food that I didn't
actually grew up eating but but you but
this journey has a large diversion
because you end up out in San Francisco
in a brokerage then you sell high-end
automobiles and then you sell real
estate and then the recession hits right
and you decide to open this restaurant
yeah I mean I was doing what I thought I
was supposed to do ya know just work to
wear a suit and tie and go to work every
day and but my entire sort of you know
time in America I just kept sort of
railing against the state of Indian food
in America right I mean it was almost
sort of offended my sensibilities that
we weren't serving food for the most
part that was what we grew up eating and
I knew how fantastic it was let me just
say I could go on and on about your
story or actually
I could listen and you go on and on but
we need you to sign our dish absolutely
and as you do this can you tell us is
there anyone past or present
did you like to share this meal with I
need you to ask this question every
single day I mean most people don't know
about me is that in addition to you know
being interested I'm a bit of a nerd
science nerd a little bit of a
astrophysics buff so I'd say if Bill Nye
the Science Guy is out the table I would
love to talk about nice boat here that's
right which of marwan irani thank you so
much and for more on mr1 and the dish
head to our website at CBS this CBS this
morning duck